Now, actually all these choices sound kind
of weird, don't they?
But the right one is this third one here and
the reason that this actually works,
is if you search using the algorithm that
we've been looking at,
if you search from V1 for something that's
not in the graph at all,
what is going to do it's just going to keep
searching and searching and searching and
searching
and building shortest paths to all the nodes
it encounters along the way
until it discovers that the node that it's
looking for just isn't there.
At the end of that process, every single node
in the graph will have a shortest path
from the--will be notated, annotated with
the shortest path from V1 to that node.
So, the running time here is just the time
it takes to do a single search,
big theta of (n+m) and then you get the answer
for all the nodes in the graph.